quatre invités politiques ce matin c'est
damien abad bonjour bonjour et put et de
lin président du groupe l'est
républicain l'assemblée nationale merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern est bon jour qui dirige le
bureau parisien du journal ouest france
on va bien sûr longuement parlé de cette
interview d'emmanuel macron damien abad
est ce qu a quand même des choses qui
vous ont convaincu dans cette interview
honnêtement pas grand chose d'abord
parce qu'il ya pas grand chose dans
cette interview peu d'annonce peu de
mesures concrètes
et puis surtout un cap une vision qui
est tout sauf claire on a une vraie
ambiguïté on nous fait le blabla sur le
nouveau chemin
la nouvelle équipe la vérité c'est que
le capitaine qui change l'équipe est la
même
le chemin est quasiment inchangé et en
fait il ya surtout un brouillard épais
sur la vision du président de la
république sur les prochains mois et les
réformes à faire pour transformer pays
vous êtes en dit autre chose hier où
vous n'êtes pas surpris de ce que vous
avez entendu
non honnêtement j'attendais une
interview plus incisive un président la
république plus offensif plus déterminés
plus audacieux aussi sur un certain
nombre de réformes
on a été globalement déçu je pense que
je suis pas simplement le représentant
de l'opposition mais c'est le sentiment
partagé par les français vous savez j'ai
l'habitude de dire quand c'est bien
c'est bien là honnêtement c'était pas le
cas sur la forme comme sur le fond et
nous avons nous sommes restés sur notre
faim d'abord cette interview qui arrive
la veille de la déclaration de politique
générale déjà ça nous interroge sur les
institutions de la vème république sur
la manière des relations entre
prémunissent ces prêts navigue tout ça
sur la manière dont l'exécutif va le
parlement aussi oui c'est le parlement
c'est un peu la dernière roue du
carrosse
c'est un peu ce qu'on remplit quand on a
rempli toutes les cases de l'agenda et
c'est bien regrettable
moi je crois à la démocratie
parlementaire et les piétinements
incessants et permanent de la mée
démocratie parlementaire
eh bien il abîme tout simplement notre
démocratie dans le pays en même temps
emmanuel macron avait déjà fait le coup
à edouard philippe en 2017 il s'était
exprimé devant le parlement réuni à
versailles le congrès juste la veille de
la déclaration de politique générale
edouard philippe
il ya beaucoup de redites finalement et
de choses qui se répètent et dans le
discours et dans la méthode
oui rien n'a changé finalement il faut
que tout change pour que rien ne change
la réalité c'est que le changement il
est simplement
dans les mots mais en aucun cas dans
l'est dans les actes ni dans la méthode
ni dans la pratique ni sur le fond il
n'y a pas de changement de cap de la
présente lui qui ne veut pas changer de
cap et là dessus et il ya un point sur
lequel je trouve que je suis d'accord
avec lui c'est quand ils disent c'est
tout sauf un gouvernement de droite
il n'y a pas de changement de caves ou
c'est pas un gouvernement de droite l'a
pas marqué à droite ce gouvernement le
premier ministre peut-être mais le
gouvernement non très clairement il ya
quatorze ministres il l'a dit c'est pas
nous qui le disons 14 ministres qui
viennent de la gauche il ya une volonté
d'avoir ce dépassement politique mais en
fait ce déplacement aurait dit que c'est
la confusion permanente et c'est ça
aujourd'hui c'est cette ambiguïté là
dessus en même temps qu'ils créent des
difficultés quand même des gros
portefeuilles qui sont détenus par des
ministres viennent de la droite aussi
oui mais derrière l'économie oui mais je
peux aussi vous citer l'écologie la
santé le travail incertaine de
portefeuille qui sont détenus aussi par
la gauche et ça va être la cohérence il
a levé par la gauche ou la droite où est
ce qu'ils sont détenus par des macros
nist aujourd'hui parce que quand on est
quand on est passé à la république en
marche en 2017
est-ce qu'on peut toujours dire qu'on
est bien de la droite où vient de la
gauche est ce que c'est encore du sens
c'est c'est une ambiguïté moi je pense
que le maquereau nisme devient une sorte
de nihilisme de ni droite ni gauche
la réalité c'est que ni droite ni gauche
ça n'existe pas qu'on habite plus nulle
part en fait
eh oui et le problème c'est que il ya
plus de 2 meur et donc il ya plus de
boussole et donc il ya plus de valeur et
à plus de conviction qu'il faille avoir
un état d'esprit ouvert
moi je suis 100% favorable à ça à ce
qu'on ne soit pas sectaire mais il ya
une différence entre le sectarisme et la
force des convictions et aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus de force et conviction pour
terminer sur gouvernement qu'est ce que
vous attendez de la dénomination des
secrétaires d'état ou est-ce qu'on en
est ce que vous avez des infos là dessus
qui va accéder à quelles paulhan on
attend sûrement rien vous savez ça c'est
du casting pour organiser un certain
nombre de scrutins détaille alain serres
il ya une déception que j'ai c'est que
on n'est pas nommé la ministre en charge
des personnes handicapées
elle est dans le rang de secrétaires
d'état ça montre que finalement ce sujet
là est relégué en 2d en troisième rideau
que plus personne n'en parle je pense
que c'est une erreur et une faute
politique majeure
vous avez ce terreau ministère ministère
délégué puis surtout une prise de
conscience une réalité moi j'ai souvenir
de déclaration présidentielle sur le
handicap sera le fil rouge de mon
quinquennat
la réalité aujourd'hui elle est
totalement inversée et je crois que
c'est dommage
dernière question puisque vous parlez
d'un changement de capitaine est ce que
vous vous l'avez compris le remplacement
d'edouard philippe emmanuel macron a
tenté de l'expliquer hier vous l'avez
compris difficilement quand on nous dit
j'ai choisi un maire d'une commune de
quelques habitants quelques centaines
d'habitants plutôt qu'au maire d'une
grande ville
j'espère que ce n'est pas le seul
critère de sélection difficilement parce
que la réalité c'est que comme on a pas
de changement de cap
on aurait très bien pu avoir le même
capitaine jusqu'au bout ou alors c'est
un problème de relations humaines mais
sûrement là il faut le dire et l'assumé
en tant que tel ça a été dit un peu à
demi mot mais la réalité c'est que les
françaises et les français ont du mal à
comprendre pourquoi on a changé le
problème liste alors qu'on ne change pas
de politique on ne change pas de cap
plus pour un changement de méthode
d'après ce qu'on a compris hier du
discours d' emmanuel macron notamment le
dialogue le dialogue social le dialogue
avec les élus
il y avait un problème concernant le
dialogue avec les élus le dialogue avec
les parlementaires avec edouard philippe
oui c'est pas avec edouard philippe il y
avait un problème avec la majorité dans
son ensemble et avec tous les
représentants du maquereau nice pourquoi
parce que il ya une déconnexion avec les
territoires
il ya eu aussi un mépris des territoires
ne pas oublier que la crise et gilet
jaune à son origine elle est née dans
les territoires et que cette fracture
territoriale a grandi pendant ces trois
dernières années elle a grandi par une
politique anti territoire en 180
km/heure la question de la taxe sur les
carburants
la xoom un enclavement que tous ces
territoires tout ceci nous montre quoi
nous montre que effectivement il y avait
une déconnexion est un besoin
certainement de retour au réel
on jugera sur pièce et sur acte la
capacité du premier ministre à faire ce
chemin là et à l'équité des genres
castex en tout cas c'est quelqu'un qui a
les pieds sur terre et qui est ancré
dans les territoires je pense que cette
critique
on peut pas lui faire maintenant la
question de jean castex est de savoir ce
qu'il aura les marges de manoeuvre et
les moyens pour influer sur cette
politique et surtout écoutés mais pas
simplement écouter faire confiance et
agir avec les territoires c'est ya des
rendez-vous qui vont arriver la question
par exemple de la proportionnelle
intégrale
on peut dire ce qu'on veut plus si
demain on met une proportionnelle à
l'assemblée nationale on ne pourra pas
être l'homme des territoires et celui
qui crée une majorité ou des députés
hors sol à l'assemblée nationale donc on
jugera sur les actes et sur pièce pour
le moment en tout cas vous ne ressentez
pas de changement d'état d'esprit au
sein de la majorité c'est trop tôt
le dire en sursis sur toutes ces
questions là sur le rapport au
territoire l'attitude de la majorité
non parce que parce que les députés la
majorité considère que sont désolés de
la science qui est vrai mais qui sont
pas des élus des terribles a évolué sur
dans l'ordre dans leur comportement je
n'ai pas le sentiment en plus vous avez
vu qu'il ya aucun député qui n'a été élu
aucun à part peut-être une exception
près pendant ces élections municipales
même le secrétaire général du parti
républicain marche a été battu à paris
il ya olivier olivier ferrari me semble
un seul tous les os avant d'aller battre
et c'est quand même un signal politique
très fort de cette déconnexion avec les
territoires mais quand vous entendez
hier 1h20 d'interviews et pas un mot
notamment sur la question de la
décentralisation alors la question lui a
été posée à sa décharge mais pas un mot
là-dessus est ce que vous dites c'est
pas inquiétant c'est peut-être jean
castex qui en parlera cet après midi à
l'assemblée demain au sénat où est ce
que vous dites c'est révélateur d'un
problème les deux oui ce sera
certainement dans la feuille de route du
premier ministre on verra les contours
que pourrait prendre cette
décentralisation mais ça prouve
effectivement l'éloignement par rapport
au réel moi ce qui m'a frappé hier c'est
l'éloignement par rapport au réel et
lorgnant par rapport aux ailes du
président l'appliquent c'est pas
simplement parce qu'il a parlé
décentralisation c'est surtout parce
qu'il a oublié totalement la question de
l'autorité de l'état la question du
régalien la question de l'état nation et
c'est un sujet central majeur que
l'actualité malheureusement nous
rattrape tous les jours cette question
là et le chef de l'état il est quand
même là pour incarner ces questions
internationales européennes et
d'autorité de l'état
et ça a été je crois un grand manque
hier alors il a quand même annoncé les
caméras piétons généralisée ça c'est un
bon signal pour vous oui d'accord mais
enfin la politique régaliennes chef de
l'état ne peut pas s'arrêter aux caméras
piétons donc certainement que c'est un
bon signal que nous réclamions et
qu'eric ciotti les députés la pub lique
1 depuis déjà plusieurs mois
il faut maintenant de mettre en avant et
le port du masque obligatoire ça ça fait
partie des choses qui sont sortis du
chapeau hier pour pourquoi attendre
début août par exemple n'utilisons que
le chef de l'état disait sans doute
premier route pourquoi attendre si
longtemps pour obliger les français à
porter de masque
moi je souhaite que le port du masque
soit appliqué dès lundi dès lundi en
belgique on a mis 48 heures pour
appliquer cette mesure du port du masque
obligatoire et elle en france on a su
qu'on finit très vite on a su confiné en
24 heures
et donc je ne comprends pas pourquoi il
nous faut quinze jours
pour rendre le port du masque
obligatoire dans les lieux publics clos
sache les explications les explications
du prime isme convainc du mise à santés
pardon ne convainc pas du tout oui tout
le monde en a tout le monde en disposent
et d'ailleurs ce qui est frappant c'est
que le discours sur le port du masque
j'ai souvenir quand même du mois de mars
on nous expliquait le directeur général
santé luisa santé que le port du masque
est inutile qui n'est pas utile dans
l'espace public aujourd'hui on a le
président luca di ce sera l'un des
piliers de la politique de reconquête
sanitaires tant mieux mais faisons tout
de suite je ne comprends pas ce délai
cette hésitation encore cette ambiguïté
permanente comme s'ils étaient forcés
par les événements mais qu'au fond de
lui il n'avait pas envie de ce port du
masque obligatoire président nous dit
qu'on est prêt pour la deuxième vague
vous vous croyez là dessus ou vous avez
un doute mais j'espère j'espère je dis
simplement que qu'est ce que ça a révélé
c'est que finalement ce qu'on dit depuis
le début
chez les républicains c'est que si on a
vu suffisamment de masques et de tests
très certainement on n'aurait pas fait
un confinement aussi dur aussi
généralisée et la réalité c'est celle là
donc on a des capacités de test qui ont
été augmentés on a désormais on dispose
davantage de masques maintenant il faut
savoir si les hôpitaux sont capables
d'absorber une nouvelle vague dans les
services de réanimation et c'est là où
nous attendons le ségur de la santé
c'est sur l'organisation de territoriale
la réforme de l'hôpital public
la revalorisation nationale salariale
c'est nécessaire mais ça fait pas une
réforme structurelle et c'est historique
comme l'a dit le premier ministre penser
c'est nécessaire c'était nécessaire on
oublie de dire quand même que sur les
180 euros nets d'augmentation
il ya 90 euros qui vont arriver là dans
les prochaines semaines mais que les 90
autres euros ils seront en mars 2021
enfin pour un aide soignant une
infirmière ou maîtres ça c'est pâques
tout à fait la même chose
ils ont le sentiment peut-être que les
180 euros vont arriver au 1er septembre
et quand on voit que prendra de l'ipam
surtaxe d'habitation recul on peut se
dire que ce qui est acquis aujourd'hui
c'est les 90 premiers euros et pour les
90 restants on verra parce que ce qui se
passera dans six mois dans sept mois
personne ne le sait vous avez un doute
sur le fait que l'espagne en touche
effectivement 983 rené je l'espère en
tout cas c'est marqué dans le marbre
c'est un effort moi je salue cet effort
il était indispensable mais il ne peut
cet effort ne peut faire échapper
l'hôpital public à sa réforme en
profondeur
propos d'argent il plan de relance
comment est ce que vous voyez les choses
le chef de l'état redit hier qui aurait
pas d'augmentation d'impôts d'ici la fin
du quinquennat est ce que c'est tenable
d'injecter aussi autant d'argent dans un
délai si court pour soutenir l'économie
sans toucher aux sans toucher à l'impôt
ou et aux taxes alors oui c'est tenable
oui mais c'est la bonne méthode il ne
faut pas augmenter les impôts ni les
taxes pour nous d'accord avec l'on est
d'accord mais encore une fois on est
d'accord sur les mots et sur le principe
sauf que ce principe il dit ça et dans
la minute qui suit
il nous explique tueuse que la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
les 4 millions de ménages les plus aisés
sera reporté sine die et c'est à dire
que en gros ça disparaît et donc c'est
ça qui va passer que pourquoi les gens
ne croient plus à cette politique
aujourd'hui c'est parce que ils vous
disent pas de hausse d'impôts pas de
hausse de taxes
en même temps il y avait une promesse
présidentielle de supprimer la taxe
d'habitation pour tous les français et
dans la même minute il annonce que cette
promesse ne sera pas tenu et donc c'est
une forme de hausse d'impôt déguisée
c'est en tout cas une longue baisse
d'impôts et donc c'est en tout cas moins
de pouvoir d'achat pour des français je
le rappelle c'est pas que des gens
riches quand vous gagnez 2500 euros net
et que vous êtes un célibataire et que
vous n'allez pas avoir cette suppression
de taxe d'habitation je considère pas
que c'est une personne mais jouer que
vous défendez cette suppression de la
taxe d'habitation françois baroin dit
que c'est une mauvaise réforme et oui la
réforme était mauvaise nous ne serons
pas fait nous n'aurions pas fait la
suppression des taxes d'habitation l'a
dit depuis le début mais maintenant
qu'elle est sur la table on peut pas
faire quelque chose à moitié ou aux deux
tiers et surtout qu'on a des
compensations qui sont faites pour les
collectivités locales
ce que nous pensons c'est que ce n'était
pas forcément l'impôt a supprimé en
priorité nous préférions avoir des
baisses massives d'impôts sur le revenu
ce après permet de préserver l'autonomie
et la fiscalité locale et en même temps
de renforcer le pouvoir d'achat des
français ce n'est pas le chemin qui a
été fait c'est pas le nôtre
mais maintenant qu'on a fait il faut
aller au moins jusqu'au bout du chemin
sur la relance
stéphane le disait 100 milliards
supplémentaires qui ont été mis sur sur
la table hier on sait les républicains
très attachés au respect des comptes
publics est ce que vous dites c'est bien
qu'on aide encore plus à la relance ou
est ce que vous dites il faut arrêter
maintenant avec le quoi qu'il en coûte
non la relance économique elle est
indispensable le problème c'est où va
cet argent et comment il est financé
c'est une chose d'investir et de
s'endetter pour investir dans l'avenir
du pays ça c'est la promesse du
président l'a 6b qu'aujourd'hui mais
nous jugerons là aussi
sur pièce et sur actes en fonction des
projets de loi de finances c'en est une
autre de financé par la dette
par exemple des revalorisations
salariales ou des coûts de
fonctionnement supplémentaires
nous verrons ce qu'il en ait entendu
suspecté de vouloir faire les deux à la
fois ça je pense qu'effectivement le
brouillard sera important et qu'il y
aura certainement des lignes qui seront
franchis nous serons vigilants là-dessus
par contre oui il faut cette relance
économique mais il faut savoir 100
milliards très bien mais faut savoir où
ça va commencer à utiliser et finalement
quel est le sens des priorités il ya un
certain nombre de choses qui ont été
mises sur la table là dessus hier il ya
des choses que nous approuvons je la
trouve l'idée par exemple que l'activité
partielle soit prolongée il vaut mieux
socialiser l'activité partielle que
mettre tout le monde au chômage ça oui
et nous partageons mais nous pensions
qu'il fallait plus loin sur le prêt
garanti par l'état sur la question de la
relance économique sur les baisses
d'impôt sur la question des baisses
ciblées tva par exemple sur la
restauration sur la question des impôts
de production surtout sur l'emploi des
jeunes aussi sur tous ces sujets là et
comment la finance tout ça alors c'est
la question vous posiez et bien il ya
une partie qui doit être financé en ce
qui concerne les investissements
d'avenir qui est financé par ce qu'on
appelle la dette productive donc
notamment ci a permis d'être fait par
l'accord franco allemand
cette partie là elle est nécessaire le
reste forcément et nécessite un certain
nombre de maîtrise de dépenses de
fonctionnement enfin on a abandonné dans
ce pays toute idée de lutter contre le
gaspillage de l'argent public
mais je rappelle toujours que les
dépenses de santé dans le produit
intérieur brut en france sont les plus
importantes d'europe que l'allemagne à
trois fois plus de l'hydre animations
que nous mais des dépenses de santé qui
sont moins importantes donc il y à aussi
à travailler ce chantier là parce que
sinon on sait comment ça va finir
ça va finir comme la taxe d'habitation
ça finira par des hausses d'impôt sur
les français la priorité est à l'emploi
des jeunes c'est ce qu'a dit hier à
emmanuel macron avec différentes mesures
notamment des exonérations de charges
pour les entreprises est ce que ce sont
des mesures vous soutiendrez qui vont
paraître sens tellement soutenir que
vous savez on l'a fait on l'a proposé
mais c'est ça qui est surréaliste dans
cette majorité c'est qu'on nous dit on
veut faire le déplacement politique et
quand l'opposition républicaine de
droite fait une proposition concrète
d'exonérations de charges sociales
patronales pendant 2
pour tous les jeunes embauchés en cdi on
nous refuse cette proposition et
l'ensemble de la majorité la république
en marche votre contre mais qui peut
comprendre ça la réalité c'est qu'on
aurait déjà pu le voter à l'assemblée
nationale serait déjà pu passer au sénat
et que la réalité c'est qu'on aurait
peut-être pu prendre des décrets
d'application dès cet été et le mettre
en oeuvre cette mesure tout de suite
très sympa c'est juste parce que ça
venait de vous parce que c'est nous
parce que c'est pas le brillant la buée
qui l'annoncé et voilà il ya du
dogmatisme chez les députés du
sectarisme
il ya du dogmatisme et il ya surtout le
fait que le dépassement politique c'est
un honneur on a émis cette proposition
sur la table tant mieux ben nous vous
savez on la votera parce que on est
cohérent parce qu'on a un cap une ligne
politique
contrairement à la majorité qui n'a plus
de boussole mais là dessus on avait fait
on a fait cette proposition n'a mis sur
la table par eric woerth et guillaume
pelletier ont fait abrasion d'un autre
niche parlementaire
nous l'avons fait il avait déjà
plusieurs semaines sur la réforme des
retraites alors la réforme des retraites
c'est pas très clair ce qu'a dit hier le
chef de l'état il dit pas d'abandon
cette réforme est nécessaire mais on va
voir pour le calendrier jean castex va
faire des propositions et ce que est ce
que vous êtes super bien compris je vous
rassure j'ai rien compris mais peut-être
qu'il n'y avait rien à comprendre
et peut-être que l'objectif c'est
justement le flou vaporeux pour cette
réforme oui c'est le flou vaporeux pour
cette réforme des retraites pourquoi
parce que la vérité c'est que c'est un
report masqué de la réforme des
retraites
la réalité c'est que cette réforme des
retraites elle a été effectivement mal
emmanchée mais elle va aussi mal se
terminer
elle va mal se terminer parce qu'on n'a
pas fait de choix politiques majeurs
savez pour réformer les retraites en ont
donné six ou soit vous agissez en
baissant en augmentant les cotisations
c'est à dire augmenter les impôts sauf
d'augmenter la durée de départ la durée
de cotisation sauve repousser l'âge
légal de départ la retraite
ces trois choix qui sont faits ça vous
quand vous soyez aucun des trois on
n'avait pas de réforme des retraites en
tout cas vous n'êtes pas de financement
de cette réforme des retraites donc nous
nous avons fait une proposition très
clair qui est de dire progressivement
repousser l'âge de départ à la retraite
pour ne pas augmenter les cotisations
les impôts pour permettre aussi
d'augmenter par contre des petites
retraites les potters des salariés
modestes des pensions agricoles des
femmes seules et pariant des personnes
handicapées ce choix politique là il
n'est pas fait tant qu'il ne sera pas
fait la réforme des retraites sera
ambiguë elle sera floué mais remettre le
sujet sur la table
dès cet été est ce que c'est pas de
nature à relancer une contestation
sociale importante
est-ce que c'est par un peu risqué je
crois que c'est d'autant plus risqué que
en fait le prix à appliquer le prémice
n'ont pas la majorité pour faire cette
réforme des retraites et que la réalité
c'est que la majorité des dépit de
l'appui qu'un marché n'en veulent pas
ils n'en veulent pas ils ne veulent pas
assumer le coût finalement politique
d'une telle réforme
et que c'est une réforme difficile qui
doit être fait en début de mandat et non
en fin de mandat c'est ça l'art et du
coup comment comment est ce que vous
comprenez le j'allais dire l'obstination
du président a relancé le a relancé ce
débat c'est toujours pour la même chose
c'est de faire un clin d'oeil à celles
et ceux qui ont voté pour lui en pensant
qu'il aurait cette audace réformatrice
mais cette audace réformatrice s'estompe
au fil des jours au fil du temps et que
la non réforme des retraites
ben collera à cette majorité comme un
sparadrap le sparadrap la non réforme de
l'immobilisme de la paralysie déclare
clairement pour vous de cette réforme
des retraites elle ne verra pas le jour
d'ici la fin du quinquennat vous n'y
croyez pas soit elle ne verra pas le
jour soit le verra le jour mais que avec
les mesures positives sans mesures de
financement et qu on renverra une pause
revoyure après l'élection présidentielle
pour trouver les moyens de financement
vous savez nos fans mesures d'âge
si vous faites vivre oui mais mais si
vous faites pas de mesures d'âge mais si
vous faites pas de financement de
mesures de financement des retraites
vous n'avez pas de réforme des rotateurs
concernant un autre thème l'écologie est
ce que vous trouvez que le président
était suffisamment on a parlé
suffisamment hier aient été suffisamment
clair sur la question qu'est ce que vous
en retenez j'ai trouvé moins clair que
lors de la présentation de la convention
sur le climat
je retiens beaucoup de slogans beaucoup
de lieux communs et où par exemple sur
le fait de sur la question par la
relance de la banque ont su prendre la
place de la réforme constitutionnelle et
la question de d'inscrire le principe de
la biodiversité et la lutte contre le
changement climatique
je rappelle quand même que on a une
charte de l'environnement cette charte
de l'environnement elle fait partie du
bloc de concessionnalité que c'est
d'ailleurs jacques chirac qui a porté
sur la viande d'ailleurs chaque fois
qu'il ya une avancée sur l'écologie
c'est la droite qui la portait que ce
soit george pompidou avec jacques chirac
ou avec nicolas sarkozy
donc je crois pas que ce soit simplement
un coup de symbole le symbole est
important bien entendu en politique mais
je crois qu'il faut maintenant une
écologie au concret pragmatique du
quotidien et c'est là dessus qu'on
atteint dans le public et mon inquiétude
c'est que la numéro deux du gouvernement
alain carne l'écologie de l'idéologique
par la marque et 6 ans qui est une
écologie de la décroissance et là il va
falloir trancher
on pourra pas être à la fois pour et
contre le nucléaire on pourra pas le
premier ni ce qui nous dit moi je veux
défendre la pire nucléaire et un numéro
deux du gouvernement qui dit moi je veut
démanteler fait sonnailles mais arrêtez
toutes les centrales nucléaires
là il va y avoir un choix politique lent
même temps il sera pas possible même
chose sur l'éolien même sage sur le
bouclier énergétique donc sur ces sujets
là on a besoin créatif mais c'est sur
cette question de l'écologie et
notamment du du référendum pour qu'un
référendum il faut qu'il y ait un texte
commun entre l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat pour résumer et donc il faut que
les républicains le vote puisqu'ils sont
majoritaires au sénat est ce que les
républicains ne voteront mais tout
dépend de ce que sera le texte des
républicains au sénat comme à
l'assemblée nationale sont favorables à
des avancées en matière d'écologie à
condition que ce soit une écologie
pragmatique positive et humaine bon mais
dans tout ce que vous savez ce n'est pas
un blanc seing pour le référendum
en tout cas ça peut pas être un
référendum pour rien se veut être un
référendum juste pour inscrire six
existe déjà
si on va au référendum il faut qu'à une
question concrète posée aux français et
qu'on ait une réponse concrète mais je
pense qu'on doit du référendum le
parlement est d'ailleurs prévu qu'il
avait dit il a dit cette convention sur
le climat lors à une traduction concrète
sur le plan législatif
eh bien nous verrons qu'est ce qui sera
retenu et qu'est-ce qui sera portée et
au sénat comme à l'assemblée nationale
la droite retiendra un certain nombre de
propositions mais n'en achètera aussi
certaines notamment celle des 110 km
heure est il possible que sur un certain
nombre de points très précis vous ayez
des choses plus concrètes cet après midi
à l'occasion du discours de politique
générale du premier ministre je rappelle
qu'il sera à 15h à l'assemblée pour
prononcer son discours de politique
générale qu'est ce que vous attendez de
jean castex à cette occasion oui
j'imagine qu'on aura une feuille de
route ce plus concrète c'est difficile
et les fermiers les abstraits de toute
façon mais oui certainement
ce qu'on attend d'eux dupré ministre
c'est que finalement ils tracent ce
nouveau chemin
ce nouveau 4 p cette nouvelle
perspective mais pour lui c'est
l'équation impossible parce que comment
tracer un nouveau cap quand la veille
nous apprennent la république qui ne
change pas de cap qui présente un
nouveau chemin floue et ambiguë
et donc cette déclaration elle va être
dans un cadre très contraint avec un
prix public qui l'a dit pas de nouveau
cap avec une majorité qui reste de
gauche et avec un gouvernement qui est
fait de bric et de broc et donc c'est ça
la réalité politique dans quoi on verra
cet après midi vous allez lui répondre
cet après midi en tant que président de
groupe le savez déjà ce que vous allez
lui dire oui je vais déjà écouté sa
déclaration de politique générale j'aime
bien pouvoir réagir en fonction de ce
que j'entends et donc j'écouterai
attentivement le premier ministre mais
mes jeux wii nous allons rappeler ce
flou
cette ambiguïté cette absence de chemin
de droite finalement est ce que nous
surtout nous nous ferions parce que la
grande différence entre les républicains
et les autres formations politiques de
l'opposition c'est que nous sommes une
force de propositions dont on fait sur
les retraites ne l'ont fait sur
déconfinement l'avons fait sur la crise
sanitaire et je le ferai encore cet
après midi par un déclaration de
politique générale
je ne me contenterai pas de critiques
nous mettrons des propositions très
concrètes et une feuille de route très
concrètes sur la table cet après-midi je
vais présenter la feuille de route des
républiques cause de ce que serait la
feuille de route des républicains et de
la droite sur sur les prochains mois
vous primaire projet alternatif
oui parce que je crois que c'est le rôle
de la droite d'être une force politique
d'alternance et pour être une force
politique d'alternance il faut être
aussi une force de proposition et il
faut montrer aussi la voie et le chemin
que cette majorité y aura mal alors à
des éléments sur la décentralisation
dans votre dans votre feuille de route à
vous parce que le président de la
république a fait complètement l'impasse
sur le sujet oui il y aura des éléments
sur la question de la décentralisation
de la fracture territoriale et de la
france des territoires ça et c'est ce
sujet comporte depuis le début de mois
même lancé cette mission sur la france
des territoires
il y attend tout début de mandat est
donc oui on va on mettra des
propositions sur la table il y aura un
vote à l'issue de cette déclaration de
politique générale quel sera le vote des
républicains pour nous le vote et ricard
ne pouvons pas donner la confiance donc
on votera contre
nous ne pouvons pas donner la confiance
à une majorité et un gouvernement qui a
fait la preuve de son échec depuis trois
ans c'est un aveu d'échec prennent
réduite d'ailleurs l'a reconnu lui-même
par toute une série d' acte de
contrition here donc on peut pas faire
confiance à priori à un gouvernement
dont les deux des trois quarts sont les
mêmes avec un chemin qui est inchangé
et sur lesquelles cette politique depuis
trois ans a conduit la france en mai il
peut y avoir des surprises au moment du
vote de confiance
par exemple un résultat très serré où
vous savez je crois qu'après la logique
de groupe qui est toujours là donc j'ai
bon je n'attendais j'attends pas une
surprise par contre ce qui sera
intéressant de regarder ça sera la
manière dont le gouvernement philippe le
nombre de pourrait d'abstention et de
compte quel gouvernement philippe le
nombre de courts d'abstention de compte
cora vous vous lavez revenus de castex
dans la question très rapidement damien
bas de votre nom a circulé au moment du
remaniement vous avez été contactées ou
pas écoutez j'ai déjà dit à plusieurs
reprises quand vous est clair que les
messages sont passés clairement la
question ne se pose pas et donc il ya
pas nous il n'y a pas eu jeu
il n'y a pas eu de contacts directs avec
le président de la république et donc
les choses ont été très claires pourquoi
parce que dès le début j'ai dit et je le
redis encore devant vous non seulement
que je suis heureux comme président de
groupe mais que voilà je préfère être
président de mon groupe
avec 104 députés donc je suis fier tous
les matins de pouvoir présider ce groupe
présent gage est plutôt que d'être
finalement faire l'objet finalement
notre débauche un poste de secrétaire
d'état ce qui nous intéresse pas non je
vous rassure pas les pieds tout à
l'heure alors non d'abord parce que je
comme j'ai dit je suis prise en groupe
et ensuite je fais à question du
handicap
je crois que ce qui est important c'est
pas simplement je crois que je dis c'est
pas simplement le combat des personnes
handicapées contre tous c'est le combat
de tous pour les personnes handicapées
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous